he is coach Jim Harbaugh how are you
coach I'm doing good rich how you doing
I am doing just fine let's let's talk
about the the game in Purdue where do
you place the offense right now based on
where you'd like it to be
coach improving it's a season of
increases for us I I felt that our team
played a hard-fought game showed a lot
of resilience won you're allowed to win
the late rounds and that's what our team
did offensively defensively and special
teams okay and how is your house Oh
Wilton spate doing best you can tell
right now well we're still assessing
that rich okay and was was that hit was
that hit with Wilton coach was that was
that legal in all honesty sitting there
watching it from my couch and it
certainly looked like that was an extra
hit on Wilton spate that might have
knocked him out of the game yes okay
and in this bye week is this something
that you're gonna assess the position
regardless of health coach we are first
we're in an improvement week we don't we
don't refer to it as a bye week ice
bridge okay no I was just are you going
to assess the position regardless of
health at the quarterback spot between
oh corn and and Wilton spake moving
forward coach I know we feel we feel
good about the position I don't think
there's any more assessing that needs to
take place and if your question is if
there's a a QB battle or I think that's
where you're trying to go with this am i
right well should I just walk in through
the front doors that were you're saying
coach mean we know each other we know
each other we go way back oh all right
I'll walk it through the front door is
there a quarterback competition going on
right here at the University of Michigan
no there's not and there won't there
wouldn't be until we really know the
help of of Wilton space okay
see I should have just knocked on the
front door you're right so what does
happen on an improvement week I love
that word by the way I've never heard
that one before what happens on an
improvement week coach trying to get
better today than we were yesterday try
to be better tomorrow than we were today
we're looking for improvement 1%
improvement point zero one percent
improvement get a mile an hour faster
that's what we're looking to do okay and
then there's Michigan State on the other
side of it Jim Harbaugh joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show did you get back
in time to watch any of Penn State Iowa
coach from Purdue did you watch any of
that I just I really saw I the only
place I saw was the last play and I saw
some of the highlights okay but a few of
the guys had had it on their phone
devices so we were we were on a bus and
and did watch the last play of the game
what do you think of that kids say Kwan
Barclay Oh coach what do you think of
him at Penn State a lot I think a lot of
them is a fabulous player Ben been
competing against him for two years I
he's definitely in every conversation as
being the most talented running back in
the convert in the country most talented
player in the country deserving of all
that type of recognition is there anyone
that he reminds you of from from the
next level days that you were either
playing or coaching it say Kwan yeah
well yeah some of there were some of the
really good ones rich I think when it
when when you look at him it's just the
yards after contact ability to be a
fantastic runner between the tackles on
the perimeter catching the football
blocking he he really is that type of
back that does it all
Jim Harbaugh head coach in the
University of Michigan joining me here
on the show and by the way Jim has a new
podcast called attack each day the
Harbaugh podcast your your brother
appears on it from time to time your dad
Jack Harbaugh's on it for time to time
it's on podcast one and I want to hit I
want to hit you on that shortly here on
the Rich Eisen show before we do that
- rich what have I been up to oh gosh
you know what I was actually on the road
I was in I was in one of your former
places of business last Thursday I was
in Santa Clara watching the Rams in the
49ers I'm doing this show here I'm my
wife and I are gonna start our own
podcast one podcast starting next week
we're getting all right yeah so how
would you would you like a Niger you go
to the NFL game wherever it is and we
see on TV there and then yeah that's a
full day and yes a lot of preparation
for that goes into that what do you do
Friday what's your well right here on
the Rich Eisen show every day every day
you're doing the Rich Eisen yes and then
on Saturday I go to the meetings I sit
next to the guy who I do believe you
handed his first hand off to and it's
professional career that's correct
to my left is a man who attacks every
day with an enthusiasm that's unknown to
pretty much anyone in the room and
Michael Irvin got that right Mariucci
he's there
Kurt Warner he's there again yeah we're
all we're all right there in the room
get ready to talk football and I was
watching I was half there this week
coach cuz I was watching the Michigan
Purdue game on my on my iPad you get the
iPad going how many how many games do
you watch the same time Regis
on Sundays I watched all ten at the same
time this Sunday ten different screens
you have like a red zone channel we do
it the the folks at the NFL Network have
built a screening room they built this a
screening room just for ourselves and if
you're ever in Los Angeles at when the
seasons done or whatever we'd love to
have you any time I love it
it's Jamar ball here on the Rich Eisen
show did you and and your team discuss
the president's comments at all Michigan
as I know is a very socially active
campus from my days of being there and
it's been that way for decades certainly
when you were there as well did you talk
about the president's comments or the
team talked about it with you at all he
was it started making it making the
rounds on Saturday morning
yeah people we were there were
discussions that as we were eating the
meal etc and we played a late game four
o'clock games so uh there was there was
discussion about it sure
okay so what was what what were the
players saying was there any
conversation about having any
demonstration on the sidelines of any
sort coach no I didn't hear that I
didn't hear that you know it is the some
of the other comments they were making
the rounds on and Twitter we all read
LeBron James and and and Steph Curry and
and that was some of the most of the
discussion was you know kind of back and
forth
I just like tried every other person in
the country was was doing at the same
time well what did you think of the
president's comments I know you spoke
about it after the game I'd love to hear
what you had to say well you by read it
was as well document I've spoken out on
it and I'm I'm on the record so and I've
been on the record from the beginning
rich and for me right now to restate it
it just feels like to use a football now
analogy piling on and I mean I'm getting
a sense that this is really becoming a
political football you know what what
the players are doing whether they're
gonna take a knee or not take a knee and
it just feels it feels like a
distraction it feels like a distraction
being used by in this case the president
yeah you know don't look what's going on
in this hand you know look over here and
like you know don't look at this hand I
you know see what's going on with just
like a magician we do you know it it
just it just has that that feel to me
and it yeah I know I'll support it I'm
not I'm not I don't think it's good I
don't think that you know the that it's
good for for the country or football or
anything that that the game is being
used as a political football do you
agree I mean that's it's the sense I
have well in terms of what you just said
about look look over here and
look over here well it did strike me
that he he used the the National
Football League in a way to throw out a
piece of red meat to his political rally
on Friday night and then realized over
the weekend what what might be done of
it
others do believe that he just loves the
country so much that he's standing up
for it and the NFL is caught in between
so is the NBA to coach as you pointed
out that you're you and your teammates
at you and your your your may your
players were talking about what LeBron
James had to say and it and I'll be
honest with you while we're having this
conversation it puts me in a very
difficult spot because I think a lot of
people tune into a show like this
because they want to escape this sort of
stuff yeah that's kind of my feeling
like as I said I've spoken out about it
having sat on the sidelines and clearly
on the record so have you spoken to
Kaepernick at all lately yeah it's been
a few weeks but been been in touch
absolutely okay and and what did you
talk about this I guess with Whittier
with your brother at all cuz obviously
he was over there in London and his game
was the first one of the weekend with
with a national anthem being played on
foreign soil I'm wondering if you and
you and John had a conversation about
this sort of thing no didn't have a
chance to as you said he was over in
England preparing his duties for the
ballgame yesterday okay let's move on
before I let you go here about this
podcast why are you doing it you join it
for fun yeah during the heck out of it
if you've had a chance to listen to it
you'll you'll pick up exactly why why
I'm doing it
my dad is the star of the show I just
get so much enjoyment talking to him and
being around him in here and here in his
perspectives and his stories and just
like gold nuggets being dropped you know
just right out of his pocket I've always
been I always had that sense of just
follow your dad around follow my dad
around and just pick up these gold
nuggets
just coming out of his pockets and one
other people to have that opportunity to
that's yeah hey now is it true that you
invited shefter on your podcast coach
yeah he was good he was good he was good
rich and I'm not gonna compare chapter
to Rich Eisen as honorary captains
you're both great you knew her I was
going I was about to walk in through
that front door you had him up you had
him for the Cincinnati game and I know
he's broken you were great it'd be like
it's like the old Manning or Tom Brady
yo who's better you're both great okay
all right I just wanted to make sure
that'd be what he was he was just I mean
just like you and you know that the love
of Michigan's and how much pride you
have in the school and and what a great
experience you had I mean it came so
through when you were here that were
that resonated with everybody here and
it did with Adam Schefter I mean wow and
the pride that we all had that you guys
are doing so well and and you think so
highly and of what the school that we
are all a part of so it was he was on
your level okay okay and and and I got
to ask which one am I am I Brady or
Manning which one which one you think
one can't be great why can't both be
great well I'll just take Brady because
he's the better-looking one that's all
haven't said all right can I say such a
thing like that it's your show it's a
rich and you could say what what you
what you wish on the attack each day the
Harbaugh's podcast coach appreciate it
enjoy improvement week and we'll chat
down the line you got at coach Jim for
um Jim Harbaugh at the University of
Michigan the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy